does discipline ever fail you
no actually discipline does not fail me
I fail discipline days where I live the
path and on to the slippery slope of
weakness it is discipline is my fault
I'm the one that's being weak
I'm the one that that's not hold the
line I'm the one that is deciding to
take the short term gratification
instead of the long term domination when
laziness re-zip it's not it's not
discipline that opens the door it's me
it's me
rationalizing
weighing and justifying that laziness
when I decide to take the easy path
instead of the righteous path of
discipline that is my decision that's
all of it it's me deciding to cave to my
weaknesses and become a slave to them
when I make that error when I let
discipline down there's only one thing
to do let's get back on the path get
back on I can step it up and go harder
and push more and pay for your
transgressions cleanse yourself in the
fire and the suffering of
and get back upon the path the hard
unrelenting path of discipline back path
that leads to freedom